what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today the first
episode of squid game we know nothing
about this series we're going in
completely blind when i say this is
easily the most requested show to cover
right now on our channel this is the
most requested show to cover on our
channel a couple of things first before
we go into it and enjoy our reaction
please go ahead and hit that like button
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next episode is up the goal is
to try to get these up every other day
full-length watch-alongs where you
single with the time code for squad game
will be over our patreon page we cover a
whole bunch of shows over there as well
for the same tier you get the offshore
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included let me try something out the
first episode for squid game the watch
along is going to be in the description
box going to be free the first episode
you can go ahead click that sync up with
us the rest will be uh patreon exclusive
in the meantime let's see what all the
hype is about first time i heard about
this was i got a notification bell from
paul over at heavy spoilers and never
heard of it and then suddenly i'm
hearing everyone talking about it yeah
all
right
let's get into it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are they gonna do
[Music]
oh
my god
i hate those games you gotta stop with
these games a chance my dude
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
little girl it's a really good actress
yeah
this is your future
that's right
running for mobsters and getting second
rate claw game toys for my daughter
[Music]
this guy's like peter parker if he was
never spider-man
she's always continued
already tense
oh
well done
this could get slapped all night
oh come on
[Music]
foreign playstation
what are the squid game shapes
look kinda like yeah
oh
it's gonna be like a hunger games thingy
thingy you die yeah
squid game for real
i feel like there's
so much symbolism flying over my head
every time i hold on something i'm like
something bad's going to happen or i'm
misinterpreting this
i am
uh
oh man you better arc into a badass by
the end of the interview
you better come out buff with a robot
arm
dodge
oh you're going off the grid buddy
[Music]
that was the best sleep i've had
so refreshed
my bruises are gone
oh jesus no no no no
no
how they get the hole up there there's a
forklift yeah yeah you gotta be
forklifted in and out of bed
i don't like this no doctor doom
i got one left
oh yeah
oh
oh
[Laughter]
oh no
what the [ __ ] is going on
oh
boy
[Music]
huh
it's even got a tail
come on man you can be just like him in
the future yeah
wow
oh it's like an mcs or a nightmare
wow
is this practical
i can't tell
can't be all practical
maybe it's like a bunch of different
practical shots stitched together
oh
like a sound stage yeah i'm big a matte
painting paintings yeah
creepy
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is the front mass speaking
preparations for the first game are
complete you can dig in now
oh no no no
my heart rate just like went up
i just felt it
is this going to be gross
that's probably going to be disgusting i
guess
this is about to pop off
[ __ ] i'm fully expecting cheaters to
explode
oh
oh yeah
oh no don't move don't move don't move
oh
everyone's take off stay calm
oh my god everyone's sick oh my god
this is really narrowing it down for the
next game oh no
there's so many
no one's playing the cape
guys stop panicking
it's a good thing he's paralyzed by fear
we just gotta smile
how many times he's played this game
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
don't move your head man shut up
oh he's cause he's behind someone
oh my god
[Applause]
they really should have established the
rules a little clearer
oh
oh no
yep
this guy who is this guy i love this guy
i hope something more to him
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh wow
oh wow
who helped him oh my god
wow wow
199 better make it
jump
jump jump dive go go
go both of you
[Music]
whoever saved him is my new favorite
character that's right
oh no
wow
whoa
where are they
cool yes
wow
that's how you hook an audience yeah
absolutely wow
all right guys well because it's a
netflix show and uh usually with these
kind of shows you know you want to
take them all in first before you really
start talking about it but we don't want
to talk about it per episode but maybe
not as long as we normally would for a
weekly show since we're probably going
to be cranking these out every other day
uh but for a first episode impression uh
yeah they do a great job at uh i i
forgive me if for pronouncing
everyone's name wrong moving forward
here on out song ji hun is how you say
it
song song i think
because i know
i think i think it's song
i think might be hard
might be hard uh but well for the main
character
um
they do a really good job at putting you
in to just why he would agree his
desperation his motive
that he would do any like
it does that traditional trope of like
he's got a bunch of terrible habits he's
sleazy he's a gambling addict a bit of a
low life
but obviously he really loves his
daughter sincerely that's a very genuine
thing and he would put up whatever
facade he needs to in order to ensure
that he gets to spend time with her and
that he can bring her join clearly his
daughter loves him too
and his sympathy to is sympathetic to
whatever troubles he has so
it does a really great job at making you
care
of
like a knowing a progression of this
guy's art that he has to rise up into
becoming more masculine more manly and
be like he he needs to grow you know a
backbone here because he obviously lets
people walk all over him he can be they
do a great job of fleshing out his
character that feels so human because
it's he's someone who like you provoke
him enough he'll stand up you provoke
him enough he'll he'll get angry and
want to fight back but then when he
becomes aware of whatever situation is
in he he becomes a coward again so he
has to just really work past become
being a coward and have to move forward
and really become strong
so
with that in mind you know you get
thrust him into this situation it's not
exactly like there's there's our hunger
games quality-esque to it in turn but
there's just more than just hunger games
that has the whole like battle royale
yeah rich people watching
yeah
he's kind of more desperate
yeah a little bit those those kind of
qualities which uh is a very engaging
concept
um
and as i'm sure that we'll get to know
more of the other characters as we
progress those who survive
uh but they do a great job on fleshing
out the the tone and the world here so
far of this
introductory episode
one that is uh engaging i thought it'd
be more violent yeah yeah i thought they
did an interesting juxtaposition because
they're building you up so much and you
already have this very sort of specific
and kind of almost demented world that
they've thrust you into especially in
that really colorful like
atrium where they have all these
staircases and whatnot and so yeah
during that moment i was like something
messed up is gonna happen and it does
but i thought they they subverted it
just with tension and just with the
horror of the situation and also how
stark it is too it's just like this
these walls are lined with snipers yeah
and they're just gonna shoot anybody
who's there and so like while at first i
was a little taken aback of like okay i
thought this would be something super
gory it is like really unsettling like
the more you get into it the more you
watch it like it really lets you sit in
the tension with them and it heightens
like like that moment where the guy
grabs his collar right before he falls
and is about to be eliminated like it
makes moments like those seeing so much
more and it really catches you up in
them it's good because y'all haven't
invested you into whoever that guy is
because you're like
i don't know but i want to get to know
him i know
it's a really great pool to do it
because you've set up some characters
here who all
sort of seem like they're all kind of
out for themselves to a certain extent
but you're seeing these varieties of
like the
it's interesting a lot of the feeling a
lot of what i've seen from is this
korean cinema yeah yeah i think a lot of
what i've seen from
uh yeah because they said south i said
north korea south korea so yeah
everything i've seen from like korean
cinema often
uh they often play on these fathers just
the few things i've seen the things that
seem to make it over to the states and
become popularized
are
fathers who are desperate yeah you know
fathers who
uh have to overcome a lot and will have
to grow through usually some type of
mischievous violent or um you know just
otherwise horrific experiences yeah
some of these weird things they have to
do and so
this is not by any means like familiar
but
i am interested to see how this will all
ultimately progress and i am curious if
he survives by the end of it you know
like it i feel like
there's a chance he could not make it
out of here they really put you into the
world of no this is the kind of guy who
could die yeah yeah it came like this
so
yeah i mean the the they they did a good
job at wringing out the suspense of the
moment
um i was on edge like that you could
really feel the clock yeah and i love
the motifs that they brought around it
because
the atmosphere of it all wasn't like
in your face it wasn't like bombastic in
how they did it you know a lot of times
with like a ticking time like a clock
counting down
in a lot of
mediums of cinema and shows a lot of
times you're like the time would've been
done by now yeah
but here they really seem like they
edited it to to match the countdown and
on top of that too it's like the the
when they slowed it down that just made
it even more suspenseful
so i i thought the uh the irony of
putting that music over it of you're
hopping between the perspectives of the
the rich who are
or are delighting in the turmoil of the
poor people who are struggling with this
game
and then hopping into
the people who are the players you know
it's i thought it was really good and
i'm definitely hooked into wanting to
see
see more of what's going on
because yeah they're really hammered in
that point it did reach a point where i
was like i get it
this guy
sucks
this is [ __ ] he likes to turn he's got
the worst luck ever
just wouldn't stop he's like i get it
and then by the time it takes this
fliparoo uh where they they do a good
job on handling perspectives i thought
like the transition was done smoothly
and um
they do surprise you on
just the scope of things i would say
like that that show where you see them
all laying there in the beds and yeah
just going through the fun house of the
stairs that are all colorful and it's
like it's not for the players
you get the sense there's like a bunch
of other people watching who
who we haven't even seen yet yeah it's
not just the people who are like matched
up this is being broadcast on the dark
web or something like that yeah yeah you
get the vibe that's bigger or much
bigger than what uh we're seeing here
what is this demented like child game
running man scenario going to become and
i i really appreciate it too yeah cause
like hearing so much hype and hearing
they're like oh the show's crazy i
really appreciated that this pilot
really builds gradual yeah like it
really starts out in grounded places and
then when it gets bigger by the end it's
not like so huge that it's fantastical
but it does feel like i think they
struck the right balance of like yeah
this feels like something you could
build in the real world but that's also
kind of bigger than life and outlandish
and upsetting yeah the violence didn't
feel like overly pulpy it wasn't like
incredibly realistic and it wasn't
overly exaggerated yeah it's kind of
stark it's it's like bloody but stark
yeah it's not yeah over stylized or
anything like that because i think they
still want you to feel the harshness of
that you know it's not cool
but you can feel it it's probably going
to get
like if this is the first episode and
this whole episode was on build-up you
could just imagine that okay one or nine
probably gonna have like a pretty crazy
finale i'd imagine yeah
yeah i cannot wait yeah all right guys
well thanks for being here make sure to
subscribe and hit that like button and
feel free to leave your thoughts down
below
uh yeah we got how many are in total
nine nine nine okay eight more episodes
to go
it's gonna be a journey
and i feel smart because i'm reading a
lot that's right now you can scratch out
a book for the week all right guys
see